welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and birds-of-prey released a new
trailer that somehow turns this DC
Harley Quinn movie into even more of a
party we're wearing masks we're doing
coke we're crying Bjork is on the
playlist actually this is becoming too
much of a party for me can we just play
Catan I have covered most of the basics
of this story and the characters and
past birds-of-prey breakdowns go check
those out but here I'm gonna break down
all the new stuff that you might have
missed from this trailer more than
warning the case I predict anything
about the movie that's too accurate and
thanks you pride to see that copper
sponsoring this episode if you sign up
now at privacy comm slash new rock stars
you can get $5 today to use on any
purchase online okay let's get started
can I help you
y-yes yes you can I'm here to report a
terrible crime and what terrible crime
is that yeah I told this all wrong quick
history lesson the trailer opens with
the shot that we have seen before with
Harley breaking into the Gotham police
facility by firing what appear to be
beanbags and confetti grenades and we've
said how this movie appears to be using
Harley Quinn is a kind of Deadpool
figure breaking the fourth wall going in
and out of pop-culture bits here she
goes from this Marilyn Monroe look which
is also similar to her Gentlemen Prefer
Blondes omage but then she tips a hat to
neo and the matrix as with everything
her weaponry is tagged with tokens of
her personality bang-bang scrawled on a
barrel beside its sticker with the
Suicide Squad logo and as great as her
vocal work is Margot Robbie's Australian
accent does sneak in there a little on
the word wrong I told this all wrong so
room I can't do it I'll show the next
thing let's move on the Joker and I
broke up it was completely chill here
hardly drives the trunk into this
chemical plant this is ace chemicals the
same location the Joker and Harley Quinn
got their skin acid washed it appears
that after her breakup with the Joker
she's taken out a rage on this
significant date spot for him but
there's another Easter Egg here the gate
reads Janus corporation which is the
Gotham cosmetics company owned by who
rumen see honest black mask hello there
perhaps Janus acquired a saw they're one
big company
it looks like Harley's attempt to deal
with her breakup accidently lands her in
hot water with the black mass on to the
next clip
Brady to entice the
fierce goddess within now that I cut
ties with mr. J I'm about to learn that
a lot of people want me dead okay it's
Harley grieves with Cheez Whiz as you
know we all do music here is a song it's
oh so quiet originally by Betty Hutton
covered here by Lucy Woodward but
arguably most famously covered by Bjork
back in 1995 her music video it's
amazing directed by Spike Jones might
have actually influenced the birds of
prey director Kathy Ann's visual
aesthetic for the movie the properly
swings between these heartbroken lonely
moments two wild explosive flights of
fancy and the recurring in the song is
the speaker trying to keep herself from
falling back into that chaotic love and
allow herself to embrace solitude and
find herself as Harley Quinn appears to
be trying to do here Victor Zsasz lurks
outside Gotham City imports his face and
neck are covered in scars that he marked
on himself to keep track of his victims
but before we continue thank you to
privacy comm for sponsoring this video
privacy lets you buy things online using
virtual cards instead of real ones
protecting your identity and bank
information on the Internet
keep to your new years but being
resolutions by shopping securely online
with privacy I've signed up for so many
streaming services I can barely keep
track of it and I've resolved to do
better about that in 2020 privacy cards
allow you to control the limits on your
cards so that you can avoid handing over
the case your finances every time you
spend money online so for example I've
set up this account with privacy and
linked by bank account and I created
this court specifically for in monthly
Netflix subscription payment and then
privacy will ding you with
lightning-fast precision if someone
tries to charge the card twice or if the
card exceeds the amount that you set for
it you can keep that witch or binge to a
single month or make sure Disney Plus
doesn't become a Disney - it's a system
to protect you from your own
forgetfulness no vendor can overcharge
beyond that limit you've set it's simple
it as fast as it was really just one
click privacy also offers different
plans a free one that lets you create up
to 12 cards a month there's also the pro
plan where you can get 36 cards a month
in 1% cash back on purchases and a
team's plan for small businesses there's
also a privacy Chrome extension where
you can fill out all of your card info
to save time one click and all your
details are instantly entered head to
privacy calm / new rockstars and sign up
for an account has a special treat for
my viewers new customers will
automatically get five dollars to spend
on your first purchase for a limited
time we'll link yep that's free money
folks just go to privacy comm /c new
rock stars and sign up now and let's
move on with the rest of the trailer at
the top of that list
is this guy but it turns out Harley
describes how her detachment from the
Joker makes her vulnerable now two
enemies including Roman see on his black
mask we see his black skull mask here
which he keeps between these bondage II
looking paintings where what is a mask
for one is a form of asphyxiation for
another the hot but also a reflection of
the kind of erotic violence see onus
inflicts on others during a shootout in
a storage room aid police confiscated
pallet a cocaine gets ripped up allowing
Harley to inhale ahead like Popeye and
power up
I love how you can see that coke powder
going in her nose and when her eyes pop
open yeah definitely some pupil dilation
there and I know that face real well
from the amount of times I have gotten
hi I'm Erik Bosse I am studying a
terrible example get that get that star
way do did you see a star I don't know
it was in that stuff well that's move on
what you are so cool in this fiction we
get a sense of why each one has bad
blood with black mask Cassandra Cain
pickpocketed a big old diamond from
Victor Zsasz Black Canary was a singer
at his club who betrayed him the
Huntress killed his a BFF who could be
zas or maybe one of his other associates
out of revenge for the mob hit on her
parents Huntress stabs the guy as they
both slide down a funhouse slide and
Harley's hideout I mean if you're gonna
get stabbed mid slide is a great way to
go on to the next clip your never enough
to be building a case against him we're
gonna have to work together
sure here Renee Montoya either resigns
or is suspended from the Gotham City
police for trying to investigate see
onus notice how on the desk is a folder
where the tab that reads outlaw
production a lot productions is a film
production company known for a long time
deal with Warner Brothers I'm not really
sure what's related here but there's a
quick shot of black mask looking flat as
he and his gang depart the amusement
Milo location where Hartley's hideout is
maybe this leads to that chase we see
other shots up like he is kidnapped
Cassandra Cain here and they have to go
after a rescuer moving on
revengeance rarely brings the catharsis
we hope for yeah are we okay here seonah
stuns the skull mask looks awesome and
we get more shots of that chase sequence
notice how the set crew has illuminated
the different floors of the passing
buildings and red and blue lights giving
the whole surrounding gotham city a more
vibrant comic book panel look even if
the speed of the chase doesn't give us
much time to look at the surroundings
they still decorate everything to make
it look like a colorful party on to the
next clip okay so more action and
character moments here we're named one
toy yeah punches a dude right into black
Canary's kick and we get our first tease
of the canary cry when Black Canary hits
that high note and shatters a martini
glass margot robbie apparently gets to
spend even more time in rollerskates in
this movie with another scene set at a
roller derby with cassandra cherry
neuron and then we see Victor Zsasz
joining a couple others as a fire
machine guns in this room that seems
like the same room of the other angle of
victims that we saw in the previous
trailer made me wonder if right here we
could be seen the hit on Bertinelli's
huntresses Mob affiliated parents moving
on okay here we get a big look at the
canary cry true shockwave blasts
everyone off their feet it's nice to see
the birds of prey movie not shying away
from the comic books superpowers and
then there's a glamour shot of Harley
Quinn
diamond wiping to the title perhaps
reminding us the importance of that
stolen diamond that got Cassandra in
this whole mess and then on to the final
clip [ __ ] anakata
named him Bruce after that Thank You
Wayne guy ah but which hunky Wayne guy
bat flick or baton Singh traditionally
Harley Quinn has two hyenas named bud
and Lou but here there's just the one
named after Bruce Wayne and I love how
the hyena laughs as if he knows who
Bruce really is but it's worth pointing
out that in many other scenes Harley
wears the Bruce dog tag this mean for
the hyena does it get taken just get
killed is this whole movie gonna be
Harley Quinn is John wick if so I am in
comment down below with your thoughts on
this follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at ei vas and subscribe to me rock stars
are breakdowns of everything you love
and hey be sure to check out our awesome
new Q&A show the big question the show
that gives you too much information with
drunken demonstrations of Wolverine claw
Anatomy and Emperor Palpatine sperm
count
check it thank you for joining me and
hey thank you for letting me joke about
things that are just as Harley Quinn
would say
[Music]